- That's how I think of them.
If (censored) is being pandered
to for the 38th time like
fucking eat shit for 30 days.
Help me.
I'm helping you
every step of the way.
("Childhood" by SkillyMusic)
- [Gary] When's our train?
Quick day trip to
Baltimore for a client.
Feelin' pretty good about it.
Got to spend time with the new
Office and the CEO which is good
except for Maribel,
we missed you Mary.
And just making
every minute count.
Gotta hack the
calendar if you want to win.
We got real tough
decisions that day.
This is the framework and
we're gonna start really,
you're gonna draw this and
you're gonna show every
piece of everything.
Yeah, 30 minutes.
20 minutes, give me 20 minutes.
Got to reverse
engineer yourself.
I know that I'm not overly
productive on train trips.
I would have done a lot of
social media and reply and
that's productive because I want
to be with my fan base but right
now I'm in the depths of
organizing a lot of really
exciting changes at VaynerMedia
and is being pandered to for the
38th time like fucking
eat shit for 30 days.
Help me.
I'm helping you
every step of the way.
That was super productive.
Is there a car for us?
- [Nate] No, we got an Uber.
- [Gary] Who?
- [DRock] Uber.
- [Gary] Let's just take a taxi.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, DRock, you can film them.
("The World" by Ron Gilmore)
Rick, got it.
- Rick.
- Got it.
I'm gonna announce that
we're building their strategy,
we are.
Hey man, thank you.
Thanks, man, what's your name?
- Joe.
- Joe, pleasure.
- Can I get a selfie?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Dude, this is crazy.
I walk here every day.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Thank you.
Thanks for letting the
Ravens lose to the Jets.
- Yeah.
- I appreciate it.
Awesome.
Really nice to meet you, man.
- You too, man.
- Take care.
- Have a good one.
- [Gary] Thanks for watching.
Very productive, super
to just watch the
vibe of the team and
myself as we got off the train,
just getting that
accomplished what we had to.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- That was like phew!
That's my biggest
piece of advice.
Re-look at the world.
Why can't you have
meetings when you workout?
Why can't you pay the extra,
have somebody fly with you to
get what you have to get done.
Doesn't seem right on paper
because it's a checker move.
No, that's not what you do but
in reality if you play chess,
oh wait a minute it
makes sense financially.
It's really like private drivers
or private flights or
other things.
Took me a little while to
get over the emotion of
that's douche-y, I came
from the streets,
I don't want to sellout to wait
a minute that's a smart move for
the value of my time.
So when you have
something to get done,
get it done.
You know?
Why can't you work on Sunday and
take off Monday and
be with your family?
You can.
Yeah. Maybe that'll be
the theme of this episode.
("The World" by Ron Gilmore)
- Like, reverse
engineering the task.
Like we need to make money
this or that way or even telling
people you need to make
money this way or that way,
so yeah, very comfortable
in that environment.
Depends on the client is good.
He's been listening to Matt,
I want him to listen directly.
So for me, it's basically like
digital consulting hours
that reverse engineer in to
what the task at hand is,
we respond with that normally
against a brief but I think for
you and if you
need me to come down,
I'll come down...
All digital I think.
It's really funny,
this ironically is
like a selfish episode.
Like I'm trying to make
this episode even for me.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Yeah,
I don't do this a lot.
I'm pumped I did this.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- [Gary] This was game changing.
Straight up.
This could've been dragged,
there's been things that have
been dragged out two or three
months because I wasn't in the
slot where I could've
done this, you know?
- [Jon] Yeah.
- [Gary] Train's
especially good.
If you have four people meetings
in a plane it's a little harder
unless you go private.
- [Marcus] Yeah, that's a lot.
Do you know what terminal?
Terminal four?
- Hey guys, it's
Gary Vaynerchuk,
CEO of VaynerMedia.
I'm pretty excited about like
people opening this video and
seeing this set up
of these characters.
I'm very excited about
announcing an initiative that
I've been debating
for a very long time.
The four wonderful people
here that I'm gonna allow to
introduce and say a
quick little thing.
Let's keep it very, very short
because you can just email them
are part of a new division that
I've decided to create called
Office of the CEO.
Basically I want the
organization to understand that
when you're talking to them,
you're talking to me and when
they're talking
they're pretty much,
pretty much talking as me I just
want to hedge that 'cause I'm
gonna give them plenty of
reign to execute our thing but
I'm always here.
And we're ready to roll
this out and see the impact.